[Music]
[Music]
so i think you have to allow for some
prior individuation
in reality it just might not have
anything
like a resemblance with the things that
we experience
you can't just have the world enter your
head directly without
being filtered by your own needs and
interests
as a creature the sensory systems of any
creature human or otherwise
the structures of the perception um will
never
reflect the true structures of objective
reality my name is david malone
and this is the survival paradox we've
always felt we're working towards a
true account of the universe and the
world we see around us
and that it's an accurate picture of
reality also most of us believe
at the same time we think we and how we
experience things
are a product of evolution yet evolution
is driven by survival
not truth some scientists go further and
argue that evolution rules out
even the possibility that we experience
an accurate and true account of reality
so should we conclude that while our
biology enables us to successfully
function in the world
our experiences and theories are just
useful illusions rather than
truths is the theory of evolution itself
flawed unable even to account for the
truth of the theory itself
or can we fashion a new account of
ourselves that would give us a better
way
to understand both who we are the
process of evolution
and our relationship to reality to help
us
untangle all of that we have three
fabulous speakers donald hoffman an
american cognitive psychologist
masrita chiramuta a senior lecturer in
philosophy at edinburgh university
and lastly we have graham harman the key
figure in the philosophical field of
speculative realism
donald would you like to start have we
evolved to see
the truth about reality yes thank you
i'll start with michael watson he was a
great cook
but he had an unusual advantage
everything that he tasted with his
tongue
he also felt as the three-dimensional
object with his hands
so mint felt like a tall cold smooth
column of glass he could use his hands
in three dimensions to feel around
the the glass you can feel the weight of
it the texture the temperature of it
angostura bitters felt like a basket of
ivy he could feel the tendrils the
leaves all the sponginess of it
every taste had a unique three
dimensional shape
and as a result he was in fact a really
good cook
he able he was able to use this extra
dimension of
objects to create sauces that were very
nuanced and tasty now we look at that
and we say well you know
of course those objects aren't real but
they were certainly useful
to him and about four percent of humans
have
synesthesia michael watson's it was one
example of synesthesia
and in each case there's something
useful about their unusual sensory
abilities we don't think that they're
seeing reality
but we think that they're seeing or
experiencing something that's very very
useful
and we would normally say on
evolutionary grounds that in the
normal case evolution would shape our
senses to show us the truth
because seeing the truth will make you
more fit
but it turns out we don't have to wave
our hands and guess what evolutionary
theory might say on this
evolutionary theory is a mathematically
precise theory we have
evolutionary gang theory which precisely
says what we mean by natural selection
and so in simulations with my graduate
students and then
mathematical theorems with my
mathematical colleagues chaitan prakash
we've actually found that um it's a
theorem of evolution by natural
selection
not just a wish but a theorem that the
probability of zero
that um the sensory systems of any
creature human or otherwise
um will ever evolve to so that the
structures of their perceptions the
objects and colors and whatever else
they perceive
the structures of the perceptions um
will never
reflect the true structures of objective
reality and so
we're faced with an interesting dilemma
i mean clearly evolution has shaped us
with perceptions that are useful um but
apparently they're not
if we take evolutionary theory in its
current form probability of zero that
our perceptions tell us the truth and so
as a result i think about evolution
giving us a user interface it hides the
truth
it gives us like a virtual reality that
lets us play the game of life
but without actually showing us what
objective reality is
if you had to see reality you couldn't
actually play the game if you had to
toggle voltages
in a computer you would lose to someone
who actually had a user interface that
could play the game more easily
thank you donald graham have we evolved
to see the truth about reality
i i think there's a lot to be said about
the way in which evolution has channeled
us away from this truth although
i don't think this is necessarily solely
the workings of evolution so if we
imagine as a thought experiment
that creationism were true and god
simply created all current life forms
on the spots uh i think there would
still be a problem
the problem is the assumption that
there's something out in the world that
we can extract from the world and bring
into our mind without any transformation
along the way
this comes back to this idea very common
idea
with roots in ancient times of matter
matter is a neutral substratum that
forms are in so that we simply extract
them from the forms and bring them into
our mind
uh unaltered or not very much altered i
think there's no way to do that there's
no way to
uh translate a form from one place to
the other without changing it very much
and of course evolution
and also not just evolution but the diff
obvious differences between animal
species
uh gives us a lot of evidence of that
the fact that certain animals can see
ultraviolet or infrared
light um the fact that uh
octopus can now we recently was
discovered an octopus can taste with its
tentacles
uh the animal kingdom is legi has legion
examples of this
um as for objects i want to say
something about objects since i'm
associated with object-oriented ontology
and if some of you
have read donald's work you'll know that
he sees objects as
uh fictions i actually agree with what
he's saying that
there's no reason to think that objects
that there's anything in the world that
resembles in any way the things we call
apples and
pyramids and horses and these sorts of
things but i do think we need some sort
of
individuation in reality because
otherwise you're either starting with
this
monistic lump or you're starting with a
continuum that some then somehow gets
broken up by human perception or animal
perception into individuals
and you hear theories like that in which
it's the human mind that breaks this
primal continuum up into pieces but then
how is the mind different enough from
that continuum
uh to be able to do that in the first
place so i think you have to allow for
some prior individuation
in reality it just might not have
anything
like a resemblance with the things that
we experience when you say individuation
do you mean that there
are separate things they just may not be
the way we perceive them is that right
yes i think there has
to be separate things since there's no
way otherwise to make the passage from
either
an inter-articulate lump or a some kind
of continuum with various intensities to
get from that to the individual things
we perceive
there has to be some prior individuation
of entities in reality itself
although i don't think it has to bear
any resemblance to what we experience
mazaritha um what do you think have we
evolved to see the truth about reality
i'm going to tentatively answer yes but
it depends what you mean by seeing the
truth about reality so i just want to
impact this notion
um i think what's normally meant by this
is a bunch of metaphors like
that there's an unvarnished reality
which is the truth or
that we're taking things in as they
really are
and the ultimate version of this is a
god's eye view
so for example isaac newton believed
that everything is immediately present
to god
as if all of space was a sensory organ
of god
in the optics newton describes god as a
being who to quote
sees the things themselves intimately
and thoroughly perceives them
and comprehends them wholly by their
immediate presence to himself
so if this is our benchmark for seeing
the truth about reality
it's just obvious that we can't reach it
um
and you don't need to refer to evolution
to realize that
just in virtue of human beings being
creatures with finite minds and finite
sensory organs
um these sensory organs are in a tiny
bit of space they're not in all
of space like um the sensory organ of
meetings god
um so it can't be possible that we
immediately perceive the whole
world our take on the world will always
be from a certain perspective
from our tiny corner of space it can't
be the
view from nowhere newton's gone but this
notion of
seeing the truth about reality we should
definitely scrutinize it
um what the notion assumes is that to
see the truth means to see something
independently of a perspective
and secondly to see the properties the
thing has by itself
and not how the thing relates to us but
the properties a thing has in relation
to humans um
can be just as real as anything so color
gives us a nice example of this point
and this is the view that i spelled out
in my book outside color so if we
consider
questions like are colors real when we
perceive an object as colored
for example a lemon is yellow are we
getting the truth about reality
if we take those questions to mean our
colors properties that objects have
independently of human perception then
we have to deny the reality of color
because of all this evidence that color
categorizations are idiosyncratic to
humans as woman and donald just alluded
to
so how we should think of it of this is
that perceiving an object of yellow is
due to this interaction between the
human visual system an object
that we refer to as the lemon and the
light around it
so it's perfectly viable to treat colors
as perceiver dependent properties
that is to say that they are relational
properties
like the property of being a sibling so
you know
being a sibling depends on how you
relate to other human beings
but the fact of you being a brother or
sister to someone is just as real a fact
as anything else so likewise we can say
that elements being
yellow depends on how it relates to
human perceivers
so we can grant real status to
perceiver related properties like color
and therefore we could say
that we do see reality we just have to
remember that we're not seeing
some version of god's eye view which
i've just argued as a
unreachable ideal and the wrong way to
think about human knowledge
thank you can we describe this thing we
call reality
and when we do can we actually uncover
um the truth about about these things
graham do you want to start us off on
this
sure one thing i think we've seen to
continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas